IK IS THE TIMING WE HISICD AND D
HAPPG. LIKEHE WEN TO ONTWICE TW'
TIN TO PLAY
TOUGH GUY. OH GOING TO, YOUPECTF
T  T
AND CHIEFS IN TY TO HA
ANDHAT'S THE FUNDRAISE O O
.  HE MADE OVE
IO ARE THE DUMMIES
ARE AT GIVING THEIR HARD
DIDN'T SEE ANYBODY THROWINHA
TO MAT, WE DO TOHAT IMAKES NO SE
A FORM AND THERE'SER THIS.
FI'S W
SLEWLL
HAS SECHANDCU SOMEBODYHE CUSTODF
SECRET SERVICE I,
DIFFERENT.
LET'S JY MUCH DIFFERE. I
NT RIGHTOF THESUSTTH WILL
G TO HAVE TO. HE HAS TO BEERE HS
PROCES HEARI THE SHOIS UP IN THT
WRONG. HSORT OF SECURITY ISSUESE
THE FORMER PRESIDE AGAIN
INHE
SECRET TIS HANDS
BEHIND HAC I'M TOLD HE
WON'T SPEND A
OF THEHE WON'TWOULD YOU
BE IN IN WHAT THE H
S. P BECAUERTESBECAUSE I ACTUAE
PRESIDENCY
STOCK OF THE WORLD. HRMER PRESI,
EHINGS THAT
THESE AREHI
SE LIKE
EORMERSIDENTASICD ISECORMERTHISS
UNPRENOR
CLASSY FURIS. WE'LL CALL I
, YOU KNOW OD OTH
HE DOINGND THEMANY YEARS. WT'
? INMETHING LIKEETNG ANDWODWANTT
N.E' THICKINNEDK WE'VE WHAT WAST
SHOTTED. AED SKIN. HE'S HE IS AT
GOING TO NOW. AN F A FELONY
TO HIS NAME ARE NONALDIF
I, FOR THAT MAER THAT
ALL OF THE MISTAKESHAT SO MANY
OPRO H JED T BANNO. ER THIS WHO,
YOOU PARADED AROUND
S ALL
SOMEBODY EE THATYGAVE NOW L.  NO
UNFORTUNATELY, HE'S TNE GOING, T
. IF YOU WANT TO
KNOW IS GOING TO
PP IS
T HIGH PROFILE CASES LIKETHIS, .
THE INDICTMENT OF OTHERIGILE I
EXAMPL OF WHAT THIS IS GOING TO
BEINGCESSED N WITH
STEVE BANNON BANNON
ING PROCESSED. THE
DISTRICT ATTNE
CONFERENCE. THEN THE
RA. AND THENJUNSEALED WHAT THE
INDICTMENT WAS ABOUT. IT WAS
EXPEDITEDD THATPROBAB TT AS WELN
TO UNSEAL THE IIC
SHOULD WITH YOU. MY QUESTION, I
BECAUSE I NEVER HAD THAT. OKAY.
DO YOU FEEL VIIC
ISN'T AN EICATION THAFOLLED. YEP
ONNITED STATES
PLAY ON WORNDICATACCOUNTABILIS E
E BOTES
TO PRISON. SHOULD SEND HIM TO. O
ABOUT YOUR RAREEEETHER
PRIDU EA THE
LAWHABE HELD
E RVOUS ABOUT YOUR SAFETY? I TH.
TO BE HONEST WITH Y AT
NEW T G
AN THAT'S ONE OF THEAT JTHINKS D
LDMP. DON'T
POLICE
MENTI MEAN, FINESTTHE WORLD. BU,
NOT JUST THE VIOLENCE  CN ON THI
TO RTYSAID
W Y DON'T
PLAYAWE, BUT
FOR YOUR OWN PERSONAL SAFETY.
LOOK I WRYVERYT WASU THE INDICTU
I'M NOT CHANGING ANY IN
TESY ASF .
MIU IMAG WTEST THEIR, UM, THAT D
SHOUNG FOR FIVE YEARSTHEEN
RO. THEYBY THE
SOUTHERN DISTRICTRK
AGAINST ME FOR THEAX ACTUAOMHAV.
LIFE THEE
, LETTFR HAD AN OPPORTUNITY GOIN
INTO MEET AND
NONE OF TH I. SOTURY THE STORY E
NO P WITH , G AS TRHR.
BEEN, IF R THE FIVE YRSE  DAVID